Це ще не кінець. Наслідки заколоту "вагнерівців" не є остаточними,
кажуть аналітики з Інституту вивчення війни.
Ватажок ПВК "Вагнер" Євгеній Пригожин, схоже, безперешкодно дістався Білорусі,
а Володимир Путін присвятив спробі заколоту чергове звернення й нараду із силовиками.
Що похід Пригожина на Москву означатиме для України?
І чи зможе повторитися в майбутньому?
Західні аналітики зазначають, що заколот колишнього "кухаря Путіна"
не мав особливого впливу на бойові дії в Україні.
Водночас ЗСУ можуть скористатися падінням бойового духу російських військових і нестабільністю в Росії.
Військовий експерт Олександр Мусієнко відзначає певні успіхи української армії за час, поки тривав заколот.
Україна цим скористалася. Тим, що покращила положення на певних ділянках фронту й дійсно йшла в атаку.
Є певні успіхи в районі Бахмуту, на флангах. Певне просування на півдні.
Але звісно, якби ситуація розвивалася по гіршому сценарію в Росії,
не виключаю, що ми б це використали і за кілька днів були в Мелітополі й навіть в Бердянську.
Деякі аналітики застерігають, що Путін може вдатися до ескалації бойових дій в Україні -
аби зайвий раз продемонструвати силу.
У зовнішніх справах, надто у війні в Україні, він робитиме все можливе,
ще більше тиснутиме на армію, щоб продемонструвати світу і населенню Росії,
що він - такий же сильний лідер, яким був раніше.
Водночас німецький експерт Штефан Майстер вважає, що Путін зосередиться на внутрішніх справах.
Тому варто очікувати покарання для "зрадника" Пригожина й новий виток пропаганди всередині Росії.
Люди в Росії перебувають у ще менш безпечній ситуації, ніж раніше.
Путін може ще більше піддаватися параної через можливі заколоти,
а це означатиме суворіші репресії.
Це радше стосується внутрішніх справ і людей в Росії, аніж України чи Заходу.
На початку червня найманці ПВК "Вагнер" вийшли з Бахмута, який так і не змогли повністю захопити.
Їх замінили регулярні війська РФ.
Це означає, що в активних бойових діях останніми тижнями "вагнерівці" не брали участі.
"Вагнерівці" в переважній більшості перебували на окупованих територіях.
З Бахмуту вони були відведені в два табори на окупованій частині Донеччини, один на Луганщині.
І ще ті, які воювали на запорізькому напрямку, перебували на півдні в районі азовського узбережжя,
там, де туристичні бази лишалися, вони там розташовувалися.
Після невдалого заколоту майбутнє ПВК "Вагнер" - під питанням.
Фахівці розглядають різні сценарії.
Частина найманців укладуть контракти з міноборони РФ.
Деякі можуть поїхати за Пригожиним в Білорусь, інші - на бойові задачі в Африку.
Як варіант - Кремль може зберегти структуру ПВК, але нав'язати їй нового лідера.
Водночас, як стверджують аналітики, відсутність добре тренованих і озброєних "вагнерівців" на фронті -
перевага для українських військових.
Ця група створювалася для специфічних бойових задач, таких, як, наприклад, у Бахмуті - захоплення міст.
Нині росіяни перебувають в обороні.
Російській армії зараз не потрібні такі можливості, які мав "Вагнер".
Ми чекаємо на дії української армії, на контрнаступ, на великий бій.
Не думаю, що в такий момент Росії бракуватиме ПВК "Вагнер".
Західні аналітики певні: хоча заколот Пригожина не вдався, він показав слабкість Путіна.
"Вагнерівці" майже без перешкод захоплювали великі міста й траси,
не дійшли 200 кілометрів до Москви й відступили лише після втручання білоруського лідера.
Це доводить, що всі, хто вважав Путіна генієм стратегії, помилялися.
Випускати в'язнів на волю, віддавати їх "Вагнеру", озброювати,
а потім зіткнутися з ними у своїй же країні - це НЕ геніальний план.
Путін не усвідомлював, що він втратив контроль над Пригожиним.
Для мене це означає, що людина, на якій зав'язана вся система, більше не розуміє, що відбувається,
і має обмежену інформацію про події на фронті, про війну й таких осіб, як Пригожин.
До того ж ватажок ПВК "Вагнер" уникнув покарання - принаймні поки що.
Президент Росії пішов на угоду з тим, кого назвав зрадником.
Той факт, що Путін не зміг приборкати суперечки між Пригожиним, міністерством оборони і регулярною армією,
показує, що контроль Путіна над його внутрішніми елітами ослаб настільки, що Пригожин зміг вчинити так нахабно.
Те, що він уникнув покарання і, принаймні поки що, живий, демонструє надзвичайне ослаблення влади Путіна.
Тоді як заколот Пригожина провалився, його наслідки відчуватимуться ще довго.
Очевидно, пішли тріщини. Як далеко вони зайдуть, якщо зайдуть, поки складно сказати.
Я не хочу робити припущення. Але на мою думку, ми ще не бачили фінального акту.
Поки що Путін не пішов на вимоги Пригожина й не звільнив військове керівництво Росії -
міністра оборони Шойгу і начальника генштабу Герасимова.
Та експерти не виключають, що перестановки й чистки все ж можливі.
Хоча Кремль, імовірно, буде ще сильніше закручувати гайки всередині Росії,
аналітики не виключають нових спроб похитнути владу в РФ.
Для інших може бути спокусливим вчинити щось схоже, висувати вимоги.
До того ж, коли людина, яка вбиває російських солдат під час спроби перевороту,
потім іде на свободу з гарантіями безпеки від Путіна, - це поганий знак.
На мою думку, ситуація в Росії нині далека від ясності й стабільності.
Танки на вулицях, повітряні тривоги, заміновані траси й авіація в небі.
За менш ніж добу пригожинського заколоту ще більше росіян змогли відчути на собі розв'язану Кремлем війну.
Зокрема, це жителі Ростова, який взяли під контроль "вагнерівці".
У країні дуже серйозні проблеми, і їх треба вирішувати.
Люди, які більше цього не можуть терпіти, навіть вдаються до таких кардинальних дій, як Пригожин.
Страх, паніка, бо незрозуміло, що буде, й чого очікувати, ось і все.
Водночас кількома днями раніше "вагнерівців" у Ростові проводжали, як героїв.
Хоча мотиви Пригожина й подальша доля "Вагнера" невідомі, експерти певні:
люди, які радо вітають заколотників, - це поганий знак для вдаваної стабільності в Росії.